yo yo
what'd it do it's jerry it's been a
while hi
it's nice to see you
uh i'm cruising around town but you know
what
i just saw a flick i've actually seen a
bunch of legs lately so i'm really
behind on these i'm sorry i've been gone
for so long september october the fall
generally is uh you know a busy time of
year for us horror folk if i can even
count myself among those people um
anyway so yeah um let's get right to it
uh ryan and i already did a spoilery
review for this one but i figured i
would pop in here and say what's up and
uh give you some thoughts on
interstellar christopher nolan's new um
science fiction opus
um so interstellar is the new film
written and directed by christopher and
jonathan nolan directed by christopher
nolan starring a matthew mcconaughey
it's really bad in person i can do a
better one i'm just not going to right
now
uh starting matthew mcconaughey uh anne
hathaway jessica chastain michael caine
and some other people i didn't even
realize were in it who i'm not going to
spoil it for you because you know what
that's something i appreciate in this
day and age is the ability to surprise
people with anything anymore so i gotta
hand them that big props and i mean by
now you've probably already heard but
nevertheless you know it's nice when a
movie can be like oh
cool i didn't know that was gonna be
here sweet so anyway interstellar takes
place in the not too distant future
earth has become this really sort of
nasty run-down
barren environment
all the crops and whatnot are slowly
dying
and we're trying to find alternatives
you know there are these horrible dust
storms and it's affecting people's basic
health and quality of living and the
earth is essentially dying
so we the humans are looking for a way
out of looking for a way to continue our
way of life some other way of subsisting
and so
we are venturing out into space that's
the basic gist of this movie and i gotta
give them credit first and foremost
because i i didn't i don't watch a lot
of trailers as you guys probably know
which i suppose is bad given the nature
of our channel but um you know i try to
i like the surprise of the cinematic
experience you know i like
not to know too much before i go in
because sometimes the best stuff is when
you're going cold so i only saw the
trailer for this once or twice and um i
gotta give them credit because the
trailer does a pretty good job
of
like giving you the gist but without
really telling you what's gonna happen
because there's a lot of stuff in this
movie this movie is is more akin to
something like 2001 than it is
to
i don't know something like
something else because it's been a while
since we've had a movie like this you
know one of those like deep space
exploration movies and so here's the
thing about about christopher nolan's
movies and uh i think this is true say
what you will about the way he draws
characters or the depth of such
characters blah blah blah everybody's
got a different opinion on that
but
i do think he does a very good job
walking the walk when it comes to really
tying his stories into the experience of
the characters because the thing about
this movie especially for me is i feel
like if you're sitting around dissecting
the science
and that's sort of the first place your
mind went
i feel like you kind of missed the point
like this movie yeah i mean there's a
lot about wormhole theory and space
travel interstellar travel what not
there's a lot of you know scientific
theory being at least touched upon and
played with and you know bent in various
directions but
the core of this story is human and it's
sort of about
just how hard it is to be a person
on an indefinite space mission
across various
levels of
space time you know like that's that's
the ultimate core of this movie for me
is is you know the characters and and
part of that comes most certainly from
uh the performances you know you got
matthew mcconaughey who's fantastic um
you have
and hathaway i thought was fantastic wes
bentley shows up and i i forget the uh
the other guy's name the
african-american scientist's name he's
great a lot of other people who like i
said i don't want to get into but
there are a lot of great performances in
this movie and i think the script does
do a good job
of
letting you know where these characters
are coming from and you know there's
certain points of view that get brought
up where initially you're like what and
then a moment later they explain them
and you're like i get why this person
feels that way i understand where
they're coming from i i see what their
compulsion is and i think that's a very
good strength that this movie has um
as far as a movie itself though i mean
it is spectacular and i think the only
way to see this i mean everyone says it
but that is the only way to see it is on
imax um because the way they use it is
is is incredible and you know we get
spectacle all the time you know like
spectacle is kind of commonplace in the
cinematic marketplace now and i really
do admire a movie like this where
you can actually get swept up in the
spectacle and connect to it and it's not
just like oh cool there's a robot
punching a different robot sweet
this is actually like there is
some beauty in in the composition of the
spectacle just these images of rotating
spacecraft and and various nebula things
and and and stuff like that i mean i
know christopher nolan likes his
practical stuff and there is a good
sense for that and there's definitely
some cg in there as well but there is a
lot of stuff that does you know feel
very real because it seems like they
built a lot of that you know i know
from what i've read that um he likes to
put as much of it in camera as possible
and it really does benefit from that it
feels like a real movie it feels kind of
the closest thing
to 2001 we get in this day and age and
that's a really admirable thing i think
you know i watched
transcendence uh and i i hate to keep
drawing this comparison because i have
in conversation before but you know it's
like
wally fister was talking the big game
when transcendence was coming about like
ah screw marvel movies you know it's all
about characters and it doesn't matter
if it's not about the characters and
while i do think that the two best
things about transcendence
are its two lead performances that's a
movie that sort of doesn't quite find
the proper balance when walking that
walk and i think this movie really does
because it is thrilling it is
adventurous but it is also very much
tied into
what's on the ground i think
interstellar does a really good job of
balancing technical prowess and visual
spectacle
with human content and human
consequences and that way it does become
a very harrowing journey and i think
that's one of the biggest strengths i
don't have a lot of complaints about
this movie to be honest the first act
does feel a bit choppy to me it is a bit
fast so all the stuff on earth at the
very beginning of the movie i was a
little
unsure about but once that rocket
launches and they head into space i was
in it the entire time and there's a lot
of great interplay between very
cacophonous sound and just deafening
silence
and the score is great hun zimmer
it's not you know inception i i think
they definitely borrowed some
inspiration 2001 on the score because it
is very coral and is very um
classical in a sense so this movie sort
of works for me on on most levels
um the only thing i mean if i had to
pick a complaint about christopher nolan
generally speaking is i think he's a
good writer and i do think he has some
really good ideas and sometimes i wish
his scripts would let the characters
just talk like characters instead of
pontificating so much which isn't it's
not to say that they're bad because he
does write rousing speeches
but there are
sometimes they do feel a little speechy
but you know that's my only real
complaint i think this movie you know
even if you don't think that it
ultimately succeeds at what it reaches
out for
i think you have to appreciate it
because it is an incredible undertaking
as a piece you know not a lot of people
nobody i would i would argue can do what
christopher nolan is doing right now at
the scale at which he's doing it can
play with these out their ideas and
really get into him and you get the
sense you can always tell when you're
watching a christopher nolan movie that
that there is an enthusiasm and a vigor
for these ideas coming from behind the
camera and i really do appreciate that
it's not cynical or ironic in that way
and i think christopher nolan kind of
right now is the closest thing we can
get to a stanley kubrick to a person who
can
make these huge out there things you
know they're not necessarily the most
brilliant but they are headier and
smarter and more interested in the world
around than some of the big action fair
we get these days
and um you know just as a little sidebar
i do appreciate um
quite consciously the fact that they
shot on film for this one because you
really can tell um there is a richness
in the quality of the image not even
just in the 70 millimeter stuff but in
the 35 millimeter stuff as well you can
really
it really adds to the realism in a sense
you really feel like stuff was there you
know um so that married with the
practical work that they did and married
you know with i'm sure there are
miniatures and i'm sure that there's
some cg as well but it really does bring
everything into the room um so i i
really appreciated this movie and it was
i found it very affecting you know i
mean for me the the first and foremost
thing was
the emotional resonance both from just
the sort of awe striking imagery
that you know makes you feel so tiny in
the universe and from you know the the
very uh warm and lively emotional core
that the characters bring so um
interstellar
i'm i'm definitely down with it i i like
this movie a lot you know i'm not trying
to come in here and be like oh my god
you know like i know a lot of people are
keeping praise and i know this is a
divisive movie anyway because anytime
you deal with an auteur like christopher
nolan people are going to disagree and
that's that's fine but i do think this
movie
deserves at least some admiration for
what it tries to do even if you don't
think it succeeds
um because honestly i like i i was in
the crowd for this movie
thinking to myself you know i had
kind of a douchey guy right next to me
making comments and hand gesticulations
and it just got me to thinking it's like
if you leave this movie
with nothing if you're if you just like
i didn't feel anything
i honestly don't understand i you know
which you know explain it to me
because i think that you know even if
it's not completely successful for you i
think it will at least work somewhat so
um interstellar i'm down i liked it
quite a bit definitely go check it out
imax all the way it's gonna be hard to
watch this one on home video i will tell
you that right now
so yeah um if you guys have seen it
love to know your thoughts and uh uh
what other you know science fiction is
an interesting genre and we're getting
a lot of it now so what would you like
to see in a sci-fi movie you know i
appreciated this because it it took me
back to something more along the lines
of 2001 where it's
a real space odyssey not you know a
space action movie or something like
that so you know what kind of thing
would you like to see
in more modern sci-fi now um so you know
comment like and subscribe uh check out
me and ryan's uh spoilery podcast thingy
i will see you guys soon i'm going to
try and post more of these not be such a
stranger get up off my lazy ass or maybe
stop working so hard i don't know one or
the other maybe both anyhow
interstellar is the movie i've talked
for way too long cheers